-Elisa Rojas, vous êtes avocate
du droit du travail
et militante pour le droit
des handicapés.
L'un ne va pas sans l'autre.
Votre métier est
au service de cette cause ?
-Mon métier ?
En fait, moi,
je distingue un peu
les deux.
L'essentiel
de mon activité professionnelle,
c'est du droit du travail
aux côtés des salariés.
J'ai une formation généraliste,
donc il m'est arrivé
de traiter d'autres types
de dossiers,
mais je fais toujours
du droit des personnes.
Par contre, le droit du handicap
m'intéresse à plusieurs titres,
parce que je suis
une personne concernée, d'abord,
parce que, le droit,
c'est ma profession
et que, sur le plan militant,
il y a beaucoup de choses à faire.
Le droit du handicap,
c'est plutôt l'aspect militant
de mon activité.
-D'accord.
Un mot sur le port du masque.
De toute évidence,
nous ne sommes pas égaux
face à la maladie.
Vous êtes plus vulnérable
face au Covid,
d'où le port de ce masque.
Comment exercez-vous votre métier,
en cette période
de pandémie ?
-Difficilement.
-C'est double peine ?
-Tout à fait,
puisque, maintenant,
quand je vais plaider,
il y a non seulement le stress,
qui est logique
et qui est normal
dans cette activité
- c'est toute une organisation
qui est plus complexe
que la moyenne -
mais, désormais,
je prends un risque sanitaire,
celui de tomber malade,
puisque toutes les mesures
ont été levées.
On est dans une situation
assez étrange,
où tout le monde veut oublier
qu'il y a une pandémie,
un virus
qui circule.
En fait, quand on est handicapé
et qu'on travaille,
les équilibres sont très fragiles.
-Merci d'avoir pris la peine
d'être venue sur ce plateau,
aujourd'hui.
L'essentiel
de votre activité,
c'est donc de prêter votre voix
aux sans-voix ?
-Est-ce que je dirais ça comme ça ?
Je ne sais pas.
Je dirais ça peut-être
encore plus simplement.
Il se trouve que
j'ai développé une aptitude
à me défendre moi-même,
que j'ai eu envie de mettre
au service des autres.
De la même façon,
ce que j'ai appris
dans le cadre de mon métier,
je le mets au service
de mon militantisme.
Voilà comment
les choses se sont construites.
-Justement, votre consoeur
Anne-Sarah Kertudo,
qui est à la fois malentendante
et malvoyante
et qui oeuvre pour faire entendre
la voix des handicapés
dans les tribunaux, estime que,
quand on veut défendre les autres,
c'est souvent qu'on veut
se défendre soi-même.
Vous partagez ce constat ?
-Je ne sais pas
si je le formulerais
de cette façon-là,
mais là où je peux
comprendre cette phrase,
c'est que, en effet,
je suis persuadée que
c'est le fait d'avoir été obligée
de me défendre constamment,
tout le long de mon parcours,
notamment scolaire,
qui m'a donné envie
de défendre
ceux qui en avaient besoin,
puisque je me suis trouvée
pas si mauvaise dans la défense
de mes propres intérêts.
Ca m'a obligée à développer,
sans doute,
certains traits
de caractère, etc.
Je me suis dit :
"Autant en faire un métier.
Il existe.
"Peut-être que je peux être utile
à d'autres personnes."
-Le handicap est
le premier motif
de discrimination en France,
selon le Défenseur des droits.
Diriez-vous que
le handicap est
la dernière minorité,
après les Noirs,
les homosexuels, les trans,
qui n'a pas encore commencé
sa vraie lutte ?
-Alors, déjà,
c'est la minorité,
en termes de chiffres,
la plus importante.
C'est la première cause
de saisine
auprès du Défenseur
des droits.
Je ne pourrais pas dire
de façon aussi catégorique
que la lutte n'a pas commencé,
parce qu'elle a commencé.
Des choses se sont faites
dans les années 70.
Elles sont peu connues,
mais elles ont existé, justement,
dans les mouvances militantes :
mai 68, le féminisme...
Il y avait des militants
handicapés politisés.
Malheureusement,
leur combat ne s'est pas inscrit
dans la durée
et est un peu passé à la trappe.
On le redécouvre aujourd'hui,
et c'est tant mieux.
Par ailleurs,
sur le plan mondial,
il y a des pays
où cette lutte-là
est beaucoup plus enracinée,
beaucoup plus connue
du grand public.
C'est en France,
où je pense qu'on a
cette particularité d'avoir oublié
une partie de notre histoire
et d'avoir la sensation,
aujourd'hui,
de tout devoir reprendre
depuis le début.
-Vous interrogez,
à raison,
le principe de normalité.
Avez-vous réussi,
du moins dans l'exercice
de vos fonctions,
à déconstruire les stéréotypes
liés au handicap et aux perceptions
qu'on peut en avoir ?
Dit autrement,
est-ce que les justiciables
ont des réticences
à venir faire appel à vous
ou, au contraire,
est-ce que c'est un atout ?
-En fait, je ne pense pas
que les gens voient les choses
sous cet angle-là.
Une personne qui va voir un avocat,
c'est quelqu'un
qui a un problème,
qui va voir un professionnel
et qui est content
quand il trouve un professionnel
qui peut le soutenir,
l'aider, le renseigner
et l'accompagner dans une procédure,
ce que je fais.
Je pense que c'est surtout ça
que les clients voient en moi.
-Est-ce que c'est pas un atout
d'être dans une communauté
de situation, si j'ose dire ?
-Ca peut l'être, en effet.
Moi, je trouve ça très bien
qu'il y ait moins de distance
entre les professionnels
et ceux qui ne le sont pas.
Je trouve que
c'est toujours une bonne chose
que l'on puisse trouver,
quand on en a besoin,
des professionnels
qui soient plus proches.
Il y a quand même une distance,
parce que ça reste
une relation professionnelle,
mais bien sûr que
je me sens moins éloignée
de certains parcours,
voire très proche,
pour ceux qui pourraient avoir
un parcours très similaire au mien,
bien sûr,
et tant mieux si c'est le cas.
Après,
je relativise toujours
ce qui est essentialisant.
Je ne voudrais pas
laisser croire
- je sais pas -
que ça apporte vraiment
quelque chose.
C'est très particulier.
Il y a une relation de confiance
qui se crée ou pas
entre un avocat et son client.
Parfois, ça ne fonctionne pas.
Parfois, ça fonctionne
très, très bien.
Dans ces cas-là,
c'est même génial.
C'est quelque chose
de très enrichissant.
Je comprends
ce que vous voulez dire,
au sens où je trouve
que c'est important
pour tout le monde,
que ce soit un avocat
ou un médecin,
de pouvoir avoir le choix
d'aller vers un professionnel
qui vous ressemble davantage.
-Vous luttez ardemment
contre la présomption d'incapacité
que la société renvoie
aux personnes
en situation de handicap.
-Le problème,
c'est qu'on est identifiés
que par rapport à cet aspect.
Or, la situation est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça.
On ne peut pas
être identifiés
que par rapport à cet élément,
ce qui ne veut pas
dire non plus
qu'il faut tomber
dans le travers inverse
et faire de nous des gens
qui ne sont absolument pas
limités.
Il y a des limites,
du fait du handicap,
mais pour autant,
elles ne justifient pas
que l'on soit entravés
dans notre vie.
-L'un de vos confrères,
l'avocat d'affaires
et professeur de droit
Stéphane Baller, dit :
"Toute personne handicapée
qui souhaite
"embrasser ce métier
n'a pas d'autre choix
"que d'être extraordinaire,
à la fois
"dans sa manière d'exercer
et de se déplacer."
Etes-vous une surfemme,
Elisa Rojas ?
-Non, pas du tout,
et je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cette façon
de voir les choses
et de présenter les choses.
Ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est de faire du bon travail.
Je le fais avec conscience,
avec rigueur
et avec passion aussi,
parce que c'est très intéressant,
mais je ne suis pas une surfemme.
Je ne suis pas une héroïne.
Je suis humaine, faillible.
Je suis aussi complexe
que n'importe qui d'autre.
-Etes-vous d'accord
qu'exercer ce métier
tient parfois pour vous
du parcours du combattant ?
Même les études ont dû
être compliquées.
-Oui, mais ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est d'essayer de comprendre
quel est le système
qui transforme ce parcours
en parcours du combattant.
Dans le cadre professionnel,
il est dangereux
qu'on soumette
les personnes handicapées
à une exigence supplémentaire.
Le fait d'être compétent
doit suffire
à nous prendre au sérieux
en tant que professionnels.
On n'a pas à répondre
à cette exigence d'être surhumain.
Ca me paraît absolument injuste.
Si les gens cherchent une héroïne,
faut pas frapper à ma porte.
Faut aller voir
ceux qui aiment
jouer aux héros.
C'est pas mon cas.
-Est-ce que le milieu de l'avocature
est un milieu inclusif ?
Il était pas réputé comme tel.
Est-ce que ça a changé ?
-Est-ce que ça a changé ?
C'est difficile à dire.
Je n'ai pas beaucoup de chiffres
et d'indicateurs pour l'affirmer.
Quand j'ai commencé,
je ne peux pas considérer que
c'était un milieu inclusif.
Je pense
honnêtement qu'il est
à l'image de la société,
de plein d'autres secteurs
professionnels.
Ce qui est gênant,
c'est que, en tant qu'avocats,
on connaît les textes
en matière de discrimination.
Peut-être faudrait-il
qu'on s'interroge un peu,
en termes d'exemplarité.
On n'est pas différents.
Les difficultés rencontrées
ne sont pas différentes.
-Justement, vous pointez du doigt
une société
qui n'est pas conçue
pour tous.
La "mise aux normes"
des bâtiments publics
- commerces,
cabinets médicaux, gares,
hôtels, transports -
traîne.
Il y a eu un report
de la loi en 2005.
Où en sommes-nous,
aujourd'hui ?
-Là, on va voir
ce qui va se passer.
On doit arriver bientôt
à la fin
des reports de délai,
sans doute.
C'est déjà incroyable
qu'il y ait eu un report.
Ce report a eu lieu,
justement,
pour éviter la création
d'un contentieux
qui, à partir de 2015,
aurait pu
se développer.
L'accessibilité devenait
une obligation de résultat.
Tout équipement
qui n'avait pas répondu
à ce résultat
était susceptible
d'être mis en cause
par une personne handicapée
qui aurait pu
multiplier les actions.
Pour éviter ça,
comme il y avait beaucoup
de bâtiments publics concernés,
on a modifié le volet accessibilité
de la loi de 2005.
On a reporté les délais
une fois de plus.
On a créé un dispositif
totalement...
Une usine à gaz, en fait.
Ce sont les agendas d'accessibilité.
Maintenant,
on arrive certainement
bientôt au bout
de ces agendas.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
C'est une bonne question,
sur le plan judiciaire.
Va-t-on enfin voir
émerger un contentieux
qui, peut-être,
serait souhaitable,
pour que les choses avancent ?
-Vous-même,
vous avez été pénalisée
dans l'exercice
de vos fonctions,
qui s'apparente parfois
à une épreuve
de "Pékin express".
Vous vous êtes retrouvée
dans la cuisine
du conseil des prud'hommes
de Villeneuve-Saint-Georges ?
-Oui, enfin...
Ce qui s'est passé,
c'est que, ce jour-là,
j'arrive pour l'audience.
Je m'aperçois que
la salle est à l'étage
et qu'il n'y a pas d'ascenseur.
Ce jour-là, je n'ai pas eu envie
de faire comme si de rien n'était
et de me faire porter
pour accéder à la salle d'audience.
J'ai signalé
qu'il y avait une difficulté.
L'alternative, c'était de plaider
dans la cuisine.
C'est ce que j'ai fait.
Peu de confrères ont plaidé un jour
dans la cuisine
d'un conseil des prud'hommes.
C'était très étrange.
Au-delà de mon cas personnel,
que je ne trouve pas
très intéressant,
c'est vraiment l'accessibilité
de la justice
dans un pays comme la France
qui pose problème.
Les personnes handicapées
ont leurs droits bafoués
quotidiennement.
Si, le jour où
elles ont envie d'agir,
elles se retrouvent une fois de plus
devant des bâtiments
qui ne sont pas accessibles,
une justice
qui n'est pas accessible,
c'est absolument scandaleux.
-Il n'y a pas que la question
de l'accessibilité physique.
Des plaignants font appel
à des ambulanciers privés,
à leurs frais,
pour assister aux audiences,
ou ont recours à des interprètes
en langue des signes,
toujours à leurs frais.
Une femme malentendante
a dû mimer le viol
qu'elle avait subi,
faute de pouvoir le raconter
avec des mots.
Les anecdotes ne manquent pas
sur un dispositif judiciaire
pas du tout adapté
aux personnes handicapées.
-L'accessibilité,
au sens où je l'entends,
ça ne comprend pas que
l'accessibilité pour les personnes
à mobilité réduite.
C'est vraiment pour l'ensemble
des handicaps.
C'est entièrement accessible
que la justice doit être.
-Vous avez entendu parler
de cette histoire.
16 militants handicapés
ont été condamnés
en première instance
à des peines avec sursis
et à des amendes pour avoir bloqué
la gare et l'aéroport
de Toulouse,
en 2018.
Ces "dangereux activistes"
réclamaient une chose :
le droit de vivre
comme tout le monde.
Que vous inspirent
ces actions de désobéissance civile
et ce jugement ?
-Ce jugement, je le trouve triste,
parce que je pense que
criminaliser les actions militantes,
quelles qu'elles soient,
c'est pour silencier les gens,
les effrayer.
Je trouve ça assez triste.
Surtout, ce qui est incroyable
dans cette histoire,
c'est que,
en première instance,
il y avait des problèmes
d'accessibilité
pour la tenue de l'audience.
La justice veut criminaliser
des militants handicapés,
mais n'a pas les moyens de les juger
dans des conditions dignes
et de leur offrir
un procès équitable,
ce qui montre que
la raison pour laquelle ils ont agi,
même illégalement,
était parfaitement fondée.
Cette affaire,
je la connais d'autant mieux
que j'ai été citée par l'association
comme témoin
pour les soutenir en appel.
Voilà. Enfin...
J'ai considéré
qu'il était totalement naturel
d'apporter mon soutien
à des militants
qui ont pris des risques
pour toutes
les personnes handicapées
dans la même situation.
Quand on fait du droit,
on sait une chose très importante.
Il y a ce qui est juste
et ce qui est légal.
Parfois, ce qui est illégal
peut être juste.
Il faut bien faire la distinction.
A travers l'histoire,
il y a des gens qui ont su
faire la distinction.
Pour que les choses changent,
bougent,
parfois, il faut en passer
par des actions de ce type.
-Maître, le droit,
c'est la mise en oeuvre
d'une politique.
Se battre sur le plan judiciaire,
c'est la meilleure façon
de faire progresser
les lois et le politique ?
-Je pense que
le droit est un outil de lutte.
C'est l'un des outils.
C'est pas magique.
On ne peut pas tout attendre
et tout ne peut pas
résulter des procédures,
mais puisque c'est un outil,
il faut l'utiliser.
Parfois, il permet
de faire avancer les choses.
Il y a eu beaucoup d'exemples,
à travers les combats sociaux
qui ont été menés,
qui montrent l'intérêt,
également,
de se servir du droit
comme d'un outil.
-Vous vous étiez
fait connaître en 2004,
après une tribune incendiaire
dans Le Monde
contre le Téléthon,
auquel vous reprochiez
une vision larmoyante,
misérabiliste et charitable
du handicap.
Les choses n'ont pas bougé ?
-Non.
Je n'ai pas la sensation
qu'on aille vers le progrès
et c'est ça que je trouve
particulièrement inquiétant.
On est plutôt dans une régression,
en termes de droits
pour les personnes handicapées.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Il y a eu pas mal de réformes
qui ne sont pas des réformes
qui vont dans le sens
de l'émancipation et de l'égalité,
ne serait-ce que,
par exemple, la loi ELAN.
La réduction du nombre
de logements accessibles
dans le bâtiment neuf,
c'est une régression.
-Philippe Croizon,
que nous avions reçu ici
pour évoquer son parcours
et changer le regard
sur le handicap,
est dans une démarche apolitique,
contrairement à vous.
En quoi politiser le handicap
est pour vous une nécessité ?
-Alors, je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait un quelconque sujet
qui soit apolitique.
Je ne crois pas en l'existence
de personnes
ou de sujets apolitiques.
-Tout est politique ?
-Oui, parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'on s'interroge,
on en arrive toujours
à une question de fond,
qui est fondamentale
et qui est :
dans quelle société
on souhaite vivre ?
C'est à ça
que renvoie chaque débat,
donc le handicap,
la santé, le Covid,
tout ça, ce sont des choix
et des questions politiques.
Je sais personnellement
dans quel type de société
j'ai envie de vivre.
Voilà.
Je vais dans ce sens
et je défends
tout ce qui peut permettre
de construire
cette société-là :
une société d'égalité,
de justice,
de justice sociale
et de répartition
des richesses.
-Que vous inspire l'affaire
des disparues de l'Yonne,
résolue
après quatre décennies,
grâce à l'entêtement
d'une avocate, Corinne Herrmann ?
Y voyez-vous le symptôme
d'un dysfonctionnement grave
de l'Etat,
d'une violence
institutionnelle ?
Vous militez pour la fermeture
des institutions spécialisées
et vous pointez du doigt
les défaillances
des associations.
Peinent-elles à défendre vos droits,
les associations
et institutions spécialisées ?
-Les associations gestionnaires,
ces grosses associations qui gèrent
des établissements spécialisés
et des services
pour les personnes handicapées,
sont devenues le relais
de l'Etat.
En fait, elles reçoivent
énormément d'argent public
pour maintenir un système
qui porte atteinte aux droits
des personnes handicapées.
C'est l'ONU qui le dit.
C'est un système institutionnel
qui consiste à regrouper
les personnes handicapées,
à les couper
du reste de la société,
à les faire vivre dans des bâtiments
qui leur sont destinés.
C'est une atteinte aux droits
des personnes handicapées.
On le sait.
-C'est une ségrégation ?
-C'est une ségrégation.
Les textes internationaux le disent.
Des études montrent
tous les impacts négatifs
de l'institutionnalisation
sur les personnes handicapées.
Ca nuit au développement
des enfants.
Ca favorise la maltraitance
et les abus.
C'est absolument ahurissant
que ce soit à nous,
les militants,
d'expliquer en quoi
il y a une difficulté
sur cette question.
-L'affaire Emile Louis,
en cela,
elle est très symptomatique
de ces dysfonctionnements ?
-Bien sûr. Si les crimes ont pu
durer aussi longtemps,
c'est parce que
personne ne se préoccupe
de ce qui se passe
dans ces espaces-là.
Pour moi,
ça révèle bien l'abandon
des personnes handicapées
en institution,
le désintérêt de la société
pour ce qui peut leur arriver
dans ces endroits.
Je trouve, oui,
que c'est assez grave.
D'ailleurs, ça a donné lieu
à toute une réflexion,
qui, malheureusement,
n'a pas abouti,
sur les maltraitances
en institution.
-Permettre
aux personnes handicapées
de faire leurs choix,
définir leurs besoins
et prendre leurs propres décisions,
serait-ce un combat
que vous pourriez envisager
de porter
devant les plus hautes juridictions
de l'Etat ?
-Personnellement, je ne sais pas
si j'en aurai l'occasion.
Est-ce qu'il le faudrait,
s'il y a matière
et si des dossiers le permettent ?
Bien sûr,
et même au-delà.
Il y a des juridictions
internationales aussi.
L'important, c'est d'aller
le plus loin possible
sur ce qui peut faire avancer
les droits
des personnes handicapées,
en allant dans le sens
de leur émancipation.
-Vous auriez envie
de mener ce combat ?
-Moi,
personnellement,
je ne sais pas.
Ce que j'ai surtout constaté,
au tout début de ma carrière,
c'est que, avant d'être
en capacité d'élaborer
des stratégies judiciaires
pour les personnes handicapées,
il fallait construire
un discours politique sur lequel
ces stratégies pourraient s'appuyer.
Le problème, c'est que,
ce discours politique,
on ne le trouvait pas.
Il fallait d'abord le développer,
le construire.
C'est vrai que
j'ai fait le choix,
plutôt que de développer
ma carrière professionnelle
autour de dossiers qui concernent
les personnes handicapées,
d'essayer de participer
à la construction de ce discours
qui me paraissait
un préalable indispensable
pour aller dans la bonne direction,
pour que, un jour,
il y ait des stratégies
qui puissent se construire,
ne partent pas dans tous les sens,
sachent dans quelle direction aller.
Si vous faites des actions
pour demander plus de places
en institution,
on ne va pas dans le sens
de l'émancipation.
Si on a un discours où on sait
ce que veut dire l'émancipation,
ce que l'on revendique exactement,
qu'est-ce qui porte atteinte
aux droits
des personnes handicapées,
après, en tant que professionnels,
on est en mesure de construire
des stratégies et des actions
qui vont répondre
à ces impératifs-là.
-En attendant, vous avez été,
Elisa Rojas, sinon la première,
du moins l'une des rares femmes
en fauteuil roulant
à avoir fait la une
d'un magazine féminin
français.
Cette couverture de Marie Claire,
en mars 2021,
a-t-elle fait bouger
les lignes ?
-Moi, je pense qu'une couverture
de magazine féminin,
aussi belle soit-elle...
-Elle est très belle.
-...ne suffit pas à modifier
des structures oppressives
ou des représentations,
ce qui ne veut pas dire
que ce n'est pas important.
Je suis contente de savoir
qu'il y a des femmes handicapées
qui se sont vues
pour la première fois à travers moi,
sur la couverture
d'un magazine féminin,
mais je n'ai pas
la naïveté de croire
que ça suffit à changer
la donne.
Ce sera définitivement le cas
quand ce genre de couverture
ne sera même plus un événement.
-Est-ce que
pallier l'absence
de représentants politiques
en situation de handicap
pourrait faire bouger les lignes ?
Aujourd'hui,
il n'y en a pas.
En Allemagne, il y a eu
Wolfgang Schauble,
plusieurs fois ministre,
aux Finances notamment,
qui a promu
les personnes
en situation de handicap.
Cette promotion s'est faite
au plus haut niveau de l'Etat.
"Tout le monde porte un handicap.
La seule différence,
"c'est que, nous, nous en sommes
au moins conscients."
Vous êtes d'accord avec cela ?
-Non, pas totalement.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que dire
"Tout le monde a un handicap",
c'est comme dire
"Je ne vois pas les couleurs"
pour nier le racisme structurel.
En fait, dire que
tout le monde peut
devenir handicapé,
c'est vrai.
Ceux qui ne le sont pas
peuvent le devenir.
-Ce qui a été son cas,
d'ailleurs.
-Oui. Par contre, à un moment T,
on n'est pas tous
traités socialement
comme des personnes handicapées.
Il y a des gens
qui sont traités socialement
comme des personnes handicapées
et d'autres pas,
jusqu'à ce qu'ils le deviennent.
Je ne réduirais pas le propos,
à dire :
"On est tous handicapés."
Ca ne me paraît pas exactement
la bonne présentation des choses.
-Nous faut-il plus
de représentants politiques
en situation de handicap ?
Nous avons eu Damien Abad
au gouvernement.
Indépendamment
de ce qui lui est arrivé
par la suite
et de ce dont il a été accusé,
il a été le seul.
Il y a deux autres députés
en situation de handicap,
aujourd'hui, à l'Assemblée.
C'est une représentation dérisoire,
au regard des quelque
12 millions de Français
touchés par un handicap,
non ?
-Qu'il faille plus de représentants,
c'est une évidence.
C'est important.
On doit être présents partout.
-Vous, vous n'auriez pas envie
de vous lancer en politique ?
-Franchement, j'ai l'impression déjà
de faire de la politique.
On peut faire de la politique
de plein de façons.
J'en fais
à travers mon métier.
J'en fais à travers
mon militantisme.
J'en fais devant vous.
Ca s'appelle faire de la politique.
Pour autant,
faire de la politique
au sens où vous l'entendez,
de façon classique...
On ne peut jamais dire jamais.
Sinon, on va me ressortir la bobine,
le jour où je prendrai
une décision différente.
-Vous avez été approchée
par des partis politiques.
-Depuis que j'ai commencé
à militer, oui.
Ce sont
des démarches
qui sont régulières,
mais, honnêtement,
je n'ai pas spécialement envie
de me lancer en politique,
là, maintenant.
-Vous militez activement
pour que le pouvoir
ne reste pas toujours
aux mains des mêmes.
Pourtant, vous ne vous décidez pas
à vous lancer en politique.
-Je ne trouve pas ça contradictoire.
On ne peut pas tout attendre
de quelqu'un.
Je ne suis pas providentielle.
-Sans l'être, vous militez
pour prendre le pouvoir,
pour que le pouvoir...
-On peut être militant
et rester militant.
Qu'il y ait des gens
qui, après,
aient envie
de faire de la politique,
je trouve ça logique.
Je peux comprendre
cette démarche-là,
mais je ne vois pas pourquoi
je serais obligée...
Il y a zéro incohérence pour moi
dans le fait de ne pas
avoir envie d'en faire.
La politique, c'est un milieu
extrêmement violent.
J'exerce déjà un métier
qui comporte une part de violence.
Etre militant,
c'est aussi naviguer
dans un milieu qui n'est pas
spécialement tendre,
donc je me préserve et je fais
ce qui me semble dans mes cordes,
au moment
où je peux le faire.
-En même temps, Elisa Rojas,
vous êtes une guerrière.
-Le contexte fait
que je n'ai pas
franchement le choix.
-C'est votre mère qui vous a appris
à devenir une guerrière ?
-C'est quelqu'un de très combatif.
C'est sûr et certain.
Je lui dois mon tempérament.
C'est quelqu'un
que je n'ai jamais vu
accepter une situation injuste
ou se résigner,
qui m'a toujours manifesté
son soutien,
sans me mettre la pression,
sans décider à ma place,
qui m'a fait comprendre que,
quels que soient mes choix,
elle me soutiendrait.
Notamment
quand j'étais plus petite
et que j'étais confrontée
à des difficultés
sur le plan scolaire,
elle me disait :
"Si tu veux te battre,
moi, je vais me battre avec toi."
Donc on s'est battues ensemble
dans beaucoup de circonstances.
Il est clair que
j'ai beaucoup appris de la façon
dont elle prenait les choses.
-Elisa Rojas,
le mot de la fin.
Diriez-vous
qu'on en aura fini
avec l'inclusion
quand le mot "inclusion"
sera supprimé ?
-A ce stade,
je ne sais même pas exactement
ce que recouvre
le mot "inclusion".
Moi, je préfère les mots "égalité"
et "non-discrimination".
Là, ça me parle.
Je suis avocate.
Ce sont des termes
juridiques clairs.
Le mot "inclusion",
c'est une façon de noyer le poisson.
Même si je comprends l'idée,
pour moi, ce qui compte,
c'est vraiment qu'on comprenne
qu'il y a un système qui freine
et que c'est ce système
qu'il faut comprendre,
analyser et combattre,
pour le faire disparaître.
-Je vous laisse
le mot de la fin.
-Merci.
Elles rient.
-Merci à vous.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA